Guess what time it is?
What?
(crowd cheering)
It's time to play pop quiz.
Yes.
(crowd cheering)
(bell ringing)
Okay, it's BFF Abby,
a nurse from Atlanta.
Hi Abby, you've been selected.
Hi.
All right, have you been studying all show?
Oh, I was, I definitely was.
(laughing)
Okay, then if you can correctly answer three questions
about today's show you win a $1000,
but it's a $100 for every question you answer right.
Abby, are you ready?
I'm ready.
Okay, all right, first question,
Who gave Patti LaBelle a car?
Richard Pryor.
You got it, you were studying.
Thank God, I get so nervous.
All right.
Okay, the second question is interest news,
we talked about a bouquet that you can buy someone as a gift
for Valentine's day.
Now it's not made of flowers,
it's a bouquet made of what?
Me.
Yeeaaah!
Yes.
(crowd cheering) Yes, the best part of chicken is--
I'm gonna with the blare.
Okay.
Are you ready Abby?
Here we go.
Final question.
Here's the final question.
What kind of pasta did Drew cook in Cookbook Club?
Bucatini.
(Drew screaming)
(crowd cheering)
Yeah.
I'm so proud of you.
Abby that's a $1000.
Now, I guess that's it,
we're out of time.
That's it for the day, we're going out with a win.
We're going out with a win from Abby.
Thank you everybody, goodbye.
(upbeat music)